we had lots of questions about how the
actual dot git folder works in git
repositories because that's doing kind
of all the magic you might say and if
something does seem pretty crazy magical
like it's doing something very special
but when you start to look actually what
it's doing it's pretty simple and pretty
efficient pretty quick and it's kind of
nice how it stores everything you've
done in the past
if you wanted to investigate it yourself
which is pretty easy you can just list
the files inside the hidden.get folder
so it's a bit of work to find it but
then you can just look inside it and see
what's in there
there's quite a range of things there's
like a something called head and big
capital letters which is really just a
link to a point in your
structure and that is just a quick and
easy thing that it can always reference
to get to the latest point and if you
choose to look somewhere else then it
will just move that link to wherever
you want to look in your history of all
your files there's some things called
like config which is a folder which has
you know a range of configuration
details like your username you're
logging in with and
the kind of details about your project
that type of thing
there's um
a log folder and that's something that's
being created on the fly which you can
so if you type in git log you can see
that log list and it's basically storing
metadata about every commit you make so
it's kind of like a a summary of your
history which you can pick up very
quickly um so we can display that to you
basically
and then the real kind of important bit
i would say there's lots of other things
in there which we could talk about but
the real important bit is the kind of
objects folder
and this is all your past versions of
stored files all compressed
into this folder in different subfolders
so they can be quickly found and picked
up again
all right and so when you do a git
commit what it does it takes all your
current files compresses them with the
z-lib library and then just stores them
in those folders and uses sha-1 hashing
to get a unique name for that particular
object it creates three types of objects
basically one is it creates an object
for the commits
and one it creates an object for a view
of the folder
and then the other one is it creates an
object for each file
so
if you really want to see what's
happening then you can use something
called git cap file which is just a
command so it's git cat dash file and
then if you put do
minus t as a flag and then put in the
hash
then it will tell you what the type of
that object is the fastest way to get
and start to get familiar with it is um
to start off with git log so if you type
in git log and you'll see like a history
of your commits
and you'll see that one of the things
you get there is like a long hash which
i said it gives a unique hash for every
commit and you can copy that and you can
type in git cat
dash file minus t and then type that
hash in or paste it in and that will
tell you for example that one is of type
commit because you put in
t for type if you want to see what's
actually in it you can do git cap file
minus p and then the hash and it will
print out the contents for you basically
so you can see inside that you have a
few hashes and a few other bits of
information like who it was that created
the commit which was me in this case and
then it has a get message in there as
well and that git message is what you
said was the description of that commit
when you produced it which i just put as
testing to in this case because i was
testing so if you then want to see the
content of that commit like all the
files you had you can take that uh
tree hash the other one is called parent
hash and the parent hash is like the
previous commit so if you want to go
backwards in time you could do it that
way if you wanted but the tree is the
object which is the view of the folder
so you can do git cat file minus t for
that new hash
and it tells you it's a type tree so we
know this is a tree view of your folders
and you type same thing again get cat
dash file nice piece to print out and it
will show you the contents that will
tell you i've listed two files and each
one's got a unique hash as well
and that unique hash is a reference to a
compressed version of the object so if
you want to see what's inside that
object first we can do git cap file
minus t to see what type it is it'll
tell you to type blob because it's a
file compressed blob of
data and then git cat
file minus p for that will just print
out the contents of that file for you so
you can see it's pretty simple it's
compressed an object
it's made a text file view of the folder
and compress that as an object and then
it's created a new git commit object
which is just a summary of information
it uses and then compress that
what's interesting though is that it
stores it in a kind of unique way
if you look inside the objects folder
which we could do so if we ls to have a
look right now it's clear for
interesting so you can go into objects
and list that out and you can see that
it's got a few kind of like
subfolders which are the first two
characters of any of the commits
um and then if you look inside one of
those like with c8 one for example you
see there's
shortened file names for the compressed
objects and that's really only doing
time saving in terms of finding those
objects again so when it's trying to
call them up it means you don't have one
folder with everything in it you've got
some subfolder structure for
optimization
so but that's where all those things are
being stored inside that objects folder
it's managing all this stuff it's it's
probably got kind of root access or
something out there i mean how how does
that work in terms of security
so it's a good question i don't know the
full detail but git will only really
work within the folder that it's
managing um so if you it won't it won't
do anything with the parent folders and
it won't do anything with other projects
it's not in charge of it will just
manage the folder that that dot get file
is in the root of and all of its
children so it will stick within that
remit but you could have you know 100
folders on your computer each with its
own
git folder inside which is managing just
the changes within that
folder project essentially
and one thing i often do when i'm
showing what's happening is i
create a git project on my computer
somewhere any folder push it to a server
like github or gitlab and then just go
to another part of my computer anywhere
and then
do a get clone of the folder down onto
there and then really you can like edit
in one place commit it and push it and
then pull it down to the next place to
see what happens and you can see it
updating basically the content of the
two places
um and then if you want you can do some
clever things like change both places
separately and then try and push them
both up and see how it handles those
kind of
clashes basically they're called get
more conflicts
what does it do in those cases usually
ask you does it well a very good
question it does a few things if it can
like if you edited different files in
different places it will just merge them
for you and say you did that you did
that you know even within the same file
you edited the top 10 lines they did the
bottom 10 lines i can just
i can do that for you and it puts them
together
um but if it can't then it says okay
here's one file that has both of your
changes in it and you tell me what it
should do
so in practice it's quite complicated
um
if you on one side on the left
you
make some file changes and
push it to the server and then on the
other side on the right make some file
changes and push it to the server the
second one it will say no you can't do
that because someone else has put some
changes in you haven't seen yet and it
forces you to get pull them down to your
computer
and then it will say okay
you uh we've pulled them down and here's
your file joined with what someone else
did
and it basically puts them side by side
here and it says as a human you're
smarter than me
so you tell me which of those two i
should keep or merge them together and
you basically just delete the metadata
in between
and it will um
and then create a new commit and then
you can push that to the server it says
okay thank you i accept that because no
one has to change anything we're
interested in what happens in one more
folder and that's the index folder what
that folder does in
general is that it stores what's going
to be your next commit
so say you are creating a new file and
that's going to go into the next commit
when you get add that file it
essentially stores that information in
the index knowing this is going to be
part of the changes that are in the next
commit so when you do type in git commit
it takes that current status from the
index file and uses that as the source
of information for your git commit the
real problem is when 20 people are
trying to edit the same files at once
and everyone's doing it before you do
and you always have to emerge
so you you imagine there must be some
communication within team members and we
could do a whole video i think on teams
using that type of stuff together
d e
so d and e are children from b
so let's move that around so d
and e
and so on right so that's fairly
straightforward right now we actually do
technically split it again i think
mike's going to demonstrate this in a
second
is that we've got nothing for j is like
milk it's like water it's everywhere